there will be a substantial reward for
the one who saved the Star Wars
franchise you are free to use any
methods necessary but we want it alive
no disintegrations really kind of
disturbingly proud of myself for not
having to look up that line and knowing
it off the top my head Hey
so Star Wars news Boba Fett is getting a
solo movie that is not actually huge
shocking news that was supposedly what
josh trank was working on back before
you know fan for stick happen and he was
rather swiftly yanked off the the
franchise so the idea of a Boba Fett
movie something has been floating around
for a while so confirmation that it is
moving forward is nice to have so that
we know what's on the docket and what's
coming up but it is not exactly shocking
the more important piece of news right
now is that it has a new director as I
said it was what josh trank was working
on before but now we have James Mangold
most recently director of Logan so this
seems as far as I can tell because
whenever this kind of news breaks I best
I like get a real quick temperature read
on how people are reacting but I don't
dive into it a lot because I want when I
shoot these videos I want to have my own
opinions in my own thoughts and don't
want it overly shaded by whatever else
is being said but the impression I'm
getting is kind of twofold there seems
to be a lot of excitement about this
director on Star Wars and a fair amount
of ambivalence about this character
being being made it's it's funny I think
there was a time not all that long ago
where I think most Star Wars fans would
have been clambering over each other
with no regard for personal safety at
the thought of a Boba Fett solo movie
now you know the shrine seems to be off
the idea a bit more maybe it's because
people are looking at solo and going and
I don't know about that or they're
looking at just how the movie making
process for a decent number
the reason Star Wars movies has gone and
don't have a lot of hope in the process
churning out what they would want it to
be or maybe people have just thought
about it more realized that he is a very
thinly stretched character who was
really only ever popular because he
looked really cool and there isn't a ton
of meat there in the first place unless
you put it in the hands of a really
talented storyteller which james mangold
can be woken was good Logan was great
even absolutely don't get me wrong and
he's done directed a number of very good
films he's also directed a couple of
really forgettable films and at least
one truly awful one at least that I saw
so right now my bigger concern oh and
because it's kind of get asked otherwise
oddly one that he directed that I think
is awful is identity but you know some
of the other films that he's made that
have been good the Wolverine because he
did do the Logan move yeah the Wolverine
movie before Logan he did walk the line
which I never saw but was up for a bunch
of Oscars so it I have to assume it was
at least competent
oh he did night and day which was a very
forgettable disposable Tom Cruise
Cameron Diaz movies he did 3:10 to Yuma
which was good wasn't amazing but it was
good kind of worked his got his uh his
his bona fides as a Western director at
that point he did Girl Interrupted he
did Copland Caitlyn pulled which is a
goofy movie but it's fun for what it is
now the big headline is actually that
James Mangold is directing but to me
it's actually more important that he is
writing and directing because you look
at the guys filmography and some of the
movies that he's made he has been
involved as a screenwriter as well some
of them he is not by and large his best
movies for ones that he also had at
least a hand in the screenplay he had a
hand in the screenplay on Logan
Copland Girl Interrupted so and and his
worst stuff identity and you know we
tend to Yuma again it was fine but it
wasn't amazing it seemed a night and day
he didn't write so it seems like when
he's done as a director for hire just to
come and shoot a script he does
okay when you involve him in the
creative process and he has basically a
stake in it he seems to do much better
and produce much better work so they're
having him right and directing that to
me is the biggest saving grace because I
kind of don't care about a Bubba Fett
movie at least not overly I think there
are things that you can do and there are
ways that you can go that could feasibly
be interesting it doesn't help that they
really gave Boba Fett Oh an awful origin
story and the Star Wars prequels and now
we're kind of stuck with that so we need
to like not deal with that all I'm not
saying like retcon it away but like
let's not ever talk about that because
it's stupid but with Boba Fett what it
gives you the opportunity to do is to
just further explore areas of the Star
Wars universe that only get touched on
in the main franchise and this is the
kind of thing that I want out of these
side projects that was one of the things
I really liked about row 1 it wasn't
necessarily dealing with you know
conflicts that we didn't know went on
but it was dealing with a certain area
of the rebellion that we weren't seeing
because we were always seeing the hero
pilots and the generals but rogue one
gave us the on-the-ground you know
infiltrators assassin snipers the people
who you know you don't always want to
talk about because sometimes they have
to do some really unpleasant stuff so I
want to see those kinds of highlights to
other areas and highlighting the bounty
hunting element which gives you more of
the underworld stuff could potentially
be really interesting I do feel like
it's a chance that uniqueness is
hampered by the fact that solo is now
out which at time of recording I haven't
seen I'm actually seeing it seeing it
later tonight I'll have to review out
tomorrow which means you get two days in
a row of Star Wars videos for me so Solo
might already be occupying that niche in
terms of exploring the underworld and
the criminal element of Star Wars and
depending on how well it's doing it it
could either cause a Boba Fett to be
redundant at least tonally or it or it
could
if it totally blows it kill the interest
that audiences have in that end of
things I think what might be the best
thing to do is to actually zero in and
do something that hasn't really been
done in a Star Wars movie which is I
would say make it a character piece like
really zero in on Boba Fett as a
character and have it focused on him
have it be a really small cast have it
just deal with him hunting one guy not
like he starts out on a bounty and he
uncovers something else and it becomes
this grand no just have him a target
have him work at it have it have it be
Leon the professional in space more or
less I mean if you want to give him a
tag-along
you know character someone who so you
know he's not just standing there being
stoked the whole time that works I mean
that in some ways that's effectively
what Laura was and Logan in addition to
you know bringing the humanity out of
out of Logan as a character but she also
gave him somebody to interact with where
he grew he couldn't just be gruff all
the time if you want to give Boba Fett a
character with that function I'm not
saying necessarily actually pair him
with a kid but if you want to give him a
character to be with with that narrative
function maybe whoever hired him for
this bounty insists on tagging along
because they need to see this they need
to see for themselves that this was done
that could be a way to do it but I think
really zooming it in and again I think
James mango witty good fit for that
because when he gets character focused
you get stuff like walk the line you get
stuff like Girl Interrupted you get
stuff like Logan so I it is the pairing
of filmmaker to material that gives this
a heck of a lot more promise then the
general notion of a Boba Fett movie like
you tell me that I kind of I don't care
you tell me James Mangold is writing and
directing a boba fett movie I go okay
maybe could work unfortunately I still
have to put an asterisk on even that
enthusiasm because that was kind of my
feelings about the idea of a Lord and
Miller solo movie and no that's not me
saying that whatever they would
made out of out of their version of solo
was going to be awesome but it was their
involvement that initially gave me any
interest in the thing because they are
interesting filmmakers and we know how
that process went down and it went down
similarly to Gareth Edwards working on
rogue one and as much as the as I'm
yo-yoing back and forth so like general
premise the movie not thrilled this do
this director also working as a writer
on it makes me interested
having seen the process by which Star
Wars movies are being made really
tumultuously behind the scenes makes me
not able to gear up as much enthusiasm
as I might have otherwise because I'm
left wondering is this actually gonna be
allowed to go through to completion or
are we gonna have a clash of visions
again and then the either the whole
thing collapses or he gets yanked off
and somebody else does it I don't know
and I I really do wonder about what kind
of state the franchise is in as a whole
and this fall so gives us a bit of a
glimpse in terms of the fact cuz I think
it was kind of an open question in the
wake of solo whether or not they were
gonna keep doing the a Star Wars story
things I mean we know that Orion Johnson
is working on his own trilogy that is
not part of the the main numbered saga
so we knew that was going on and I think
I and probably some other people had
wondered also if that was going to
basically completely supplant the side
quilts and now appears that's not going
to be the case I do wonder however if
we're having that and getting episode 9
and working on a Boba Fett movie I just
wonder if if it's gonna be devaluing it
because I don't I'm starting to get
nervous about the whole idea of Star
Wars as an annual thing and sort of
diminishing returns and related to that
I'm J I'm gonna stick a pin in that idea
though because I am pretty sure I'm
gonna do a whole separate video sort of
zeroing in on that topic after I've seen
solo so I can get a better sense of
myself of where things actually are
now in terms of the films that are
resulting out of this process that's
going on with Lucasfilm as a studio so
yeah table that for another time but for
now not throw by the idea intrigued by
the filmmaker made nervous by the way
the last few of these have gone in terms
of a creative process and that's where I
land in a very conflicted place which is
basically me and Star Wars in a nutshell
these days so Boba Fett movie James
Mangold writing and directing what do
you think about this news
good bad mixed like me whatever your
thoughts are drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it dissolve
stuff to do is support me on patreon if
you want to try and help make the show
better I can be followed on Twitter and
I've got a podcast you can buy t-shirts
and there's other stuff as well I can't
even remember all the stuff I have links
to but those links are all down in the
description so until next time this
council is adjourn
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]